you have interrupted a citywide
investigation you stole evidence from my
crime scene
and you got my one lead killed I was
trying to help him but you didn't
okay Joseph stop talking who the hell
are you
My name is Matthew Murdock I'm her
attorney
how does being harlem's hero allow you
to live an actual life right now that's
what L people
I think there's somebody need to meet
hey what are you doing is that who you
who you how come she can't be hurt
what's the deal with that fist
I'm the immortal I'm just you well
you're on the same side you for the
devil of Hell's Kitchen the smartass
detective we got a problem the righteous
X Cohen down on the kid with a glowing
fish the war for New York is here so get
your [ __ ] together more connections you
have
hoping to break it looks like an idiot
your scarf
they make quite a team now are you
talking about
bulletproof blind ninja whatever it is
you are classy
sweet Christmas everybody full defenders
trailer so let's break this down there's
a new round of the giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so did not
expect this at all but there are a
couple really big things that I'll talk
about first is just totally stood out in
the trailer the first and probably the
biggest is that when stick is bringing
them together like he sort of narrates
the hero side of the trailer then you
have Sigourney Weaver narrating the
villains storyline on the other part of
the trailer he looks like he's getting
ready to train them in this theater here
like they're all getting ready to fight
him and you get this little peek at the
corner of the brain and you see two
glowing fists going up against iron fist
and everyone together so I was like wait
a minute this is very clearly part of
this stick training montage does this
mean that stick is like the series
version of Orson Randall with all these
crazy iron fist abilities that Danny
Rand hasn't learned yet that would be
amazing but it'd be a huge change from
the comics so I'll say careful for
spoilers for iron fist if you haven't
seen it yet but during that series
bakudo has footage of an old iron fist
that had the power before Danny Rand had
it and it's just a way of showing what
Danny Rand could get - if he becomes
full-blown badass because he's still
learning about his power he can only
make one fist close well it's a way of
saying that he's still iron fist in
training even though he does have the
power but then you see them all get like
blown back so there's all these powers
that stick has that we haven't seen yet
and it's all about the war between the
chased and the hand the et's all the way
back during season one it was a much
bigger thing during season two when he
was trying to use Elektra to get Matt on
their side that went sideways and then
the second big thing is that we see
Elektra back in her costume going crazy
so they're sequences during this epic
daredevil hallway fight naturally it's
on steroids because they're all together
this is like their big Avengers style
team ups but in the background Elektra
is walking behind them casually but then
you also see her punching Matt so it's a
bit hard to tell if she's on the side of
the hand or if she's on the side of the
chase because technically before she was
resurrected by the hand she was working
with sticks she was a member of the good
guys right now it seems like she's a
tool of the hand but she still loves
Matt so maybe she's just knocking him
around because she's extra crazy
frankenstein-like Harold Meacham during
iron fist but if you remember they
released that viral teaser of them in
the elevator like the stock footage of
them writing in this building here this
looks like it's the hallway after they
get out because the implication is is
the sigourney weaver's company which is
part of the hand-built this giant hole
and they're trying to bore down into
something very special so there's a lot
of the Shadowlands storyline elements
from the comics but they might be trying
to raise the beast and I love the
shawarma moment that they end on where
our fist is being all socially awkward
and Jessica Jones is just like classy
dude very classy but what it looks like
happens is that they bump into each
other separately and then slowly come
together like daredevil finds out about
Jessica Jones maybe through jeryn
hogarth maybe through Claire temple
because Claire temple is almost like
their Colson like she's the one that
jumps around to all the different series
it helps them out so we already see her
in the trailer
bringing iron fist and Luke Cage
together maybe she does the same thing
for the other characters but you have to
remember that jeryn hogarth is one of
the other big crossover characters too
so the intro was great where he just
busts into her interrogation with misty
night just being like who the hell are
you what is going on here you see Luke
Cage in Harlem still with Claire temple
just trying to help people out driving
past the barbershop Danny Rand and
Colleen wing pop up Colleen wing is
supposed to be off the chain during
defenders there been some behind the
scenes of them walking around but none
of the big action yet I'll be interested
to see a fight between her and Elektra
that would be a lot of fun the thing
about those two characters iron fist and
Luke Cage is that they're both
relatively local to Harlem even though
Danny Rand super-rich is in Midtown
calling Wings dojo where he spends most
of his time is up at Harlem so that's
the crossover where he bumps into Luke
Cage for the first time trying to stop
this criminal and I love the joke that
they have about him trying to punch Luke
Cage and him just dropping him like a
sack of potatoes and you see another
version of this Luke Cage trailer scene
from that series where the dude punched
him in his hand just completely buckles
under the force but this time because
Danny rands using the iron fist you just
hear a couple breaking sounds almost
like he's able to budge Luke Cage just a
little bit it's like Captain America
trying to lift Thor's hammer like you
just hear it squeak just a little bit
like oh yeah iron fit
at full power could probably knock Luke
Cage down but otherwise no he has no
chance in his reaction is so priceless
this is like the clear temple reaction
from the Iron Fist series you're the
what the immortal Iron Fist what the
hell is that supposed to mean in Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle style you start
getting that stick voiceover where he's
talking to all them and you had the
voiceover from that other comic-con
trailer races you can barely save
yourself how you going to save this city
so it looks like he just kicks their
butt trying to train them to fight this
much greater hand force so you've seen
no booze hand from daredevil you've seen
the other two factions Madame Gao and
Baku doze hand from the iron fist series
now you're meeting Alexandra's version
of the hand which seems like it's just
extra crazy but I think what they're
implying here is that she's the ultimate
leader of the hand regardless of what's
going on with Elektra and she seems just
like a totally normal business person
which i think is the idea like you meet
bakudo during iron fist and he seems
super zen until you find out that he's
actually a pretty terrible person here's
the thing though if stick has crazy iron
fist level powers which it looks like
they're connecting a lot of the Iron
Fist mythology to the chase maybe
they're part of one of the capital
cities of heaven because it doesn't look
like iron fist recognizes him the way
that daredevil recognized him but if he
is that powerful don't you wonder what
kind of secret powers that Sigourney
Weaver's character is hiding that's one
of the fun twists of series like that
you see someone like Luke Cage you know
he's a badass but usually when someone
is super powerful like this and
everyone's afraid of that you have Matt
Murdock in the background here like
making this like he's getting ready to
go up against her when the defenders are
afraid of her it means she's probably
crazy powerful so it's not like they're
going to use crazy guardians of the
galaxy level CG action set-pieces but
usually you see you sort of balanced
between the hero characters and the
villain characters so if stick is this
powerful then I'm just guessing that she
also has some secret power too that you
just don't see in here that's why she's
so calm when she's talking to all them
the more connections you have the easier
will be to take you down which is
implying she's willing to do anything go
after their families to stop them from
stopping the hand from achieving its
goal but it ballistically are one of the
fun moments from that earlier viral
trailer where Luke's like Matt's wearing
his old costume he is actually wearing
Jessica Jones scarf so I think we're all
hoping
that Iron Fist sees that and is inspired
to start wearing something to cover his
face but let me know in the comments
what do you guys think about the footage
and what do you think it is the hand is
trying to achieve during the defender
series are they trying to raise the
demon are they trying to get to the 8th
capital city of heaven are they trying
to get to Kunlun because that
disappeared at the end of iron fist
maybe they'll address that during this
series but what's going to happen next
is I'll post a new flash trailer video
my arrow video might not post till
tomorrow morning but if I can I'll post
it later tonight there's just so much
toughness dropping I was not expecting
this at all and there's a new infinity
war that I might not get to till Friday
or Saturday this is Star Wars so all the
things the video schedules I go along
but there's just so much stuff that's
dropping right now congratulations to
the latest giveaway winners Ark warriors
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there's a new round in
this video so just announce the winners
the next time I post a Marvel video
while you wait for that click here to
catch up on crazy flash stuff from last
night and you can click here for all my
iron fist and defenders videos thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight